ma se da tutti ringrazio per avermi
invitato a stare qui con voi stasera a
scambiare un po di un po di parole
quando accettato un invito pensavo che
sarei dovuto venire a parlare un po di
tecnologie non avevo afferrato bene
quale sarebbe stato il tema della
giornata il coraggio tema difficile e
ancora più difficile forse a dire
qualcosa di originale sulla fine della
serata
stiamo per stiamo per terminare e questo
ti responsabilizza anche perché dice
idee che valga la pena di diffondere e
non sono sicuro di avere un'idea che
valga la pena di diffondere di essere
diffuse
lo spero per occupare degnamente il
vostro tempo
se viene vietata ma lei di coraggio
perché magari possa parlare un po di
coraggio nell'impresa che è quello che
mi è capitato di fare nella vita
maggiormente ho iniziato presto a
lavorare mentre studiavo ho avuto un
lutto in famiglia che mi ha
responsabilizzato presto a 20 anni 21
anni 22
ho iniziato a fare dei negozi dei
supermercati mentre studiato a un certo
punto smesso quella volo li ho fatto
quello per il quale avevo maggiormente
studiato sono entrato in banca
nelle merchant bank istituzioni
finanziati tra milano londra ha 31 anni
ero un dirigente
avevo una opportunità di carriera
importante interessante però mi volevo
confrontare con con l'impresa volevo
essere libero per usare una parola che
abbiamo sentito oggi volevo essere
proprio gli artefici del mio destino
volevo volare volevo fare altro che era
facile essere coraggiosi da giovani il
mondo sembra tutto in discesa e tutta la
vita davanti ti sembra di essere forte
fortissimo leali possono volare le
montagne
facilmente e in effetti mi è capitato di
fare delle start up come si direbbe oggi
ho fatto una piccola catena di
supermercati che poi ho venduto ho fatto
nel 1994 internet a praga nella
repubblica ceca
avevo voglia di confrontarmi con i nuovi
paesi dell'europa con quello che stava
accadendo fuori dai confini italiani
e con questa nuova tecnologia della rete
che per chi era nato in un'isola ci
sembrava una cosa meravigliosa il fatto
per la prima volta di essere connessi di
essere insieme agli altri mi è capitata
l'avventura bellissima anche dal punto
di vista umano di portare la prima
offerta commerciale di internet nella
repubblica ceca in un paese dove ci
volevano anni per avere una linea
telefonica e dove che ci chi ce l'aveva
normalmente aveva un duplex difficile
fare accesso a internet e call duplex
comunque quella storia lì è andata
avanti è durata per tre anni nel 1998
venduto quella società fa con un buon
profitto ad un fondo di private equity
americani l'ho fatto per la volontà di
tornare a casa lo voglia di fare quel
lavoro che mi sembrava bellissimo
intelligentissimo mi sembrava di essere
dentro le cose che stavano accadendo nel
mondo e mi sembrava anche che noi che
eravamo nati in un'isola potevamo
capirla meglio capirne meglio il senso
di stare a casa e lavorare per il mondo
di stare a casa e di non essere isolati
di stare a casa e poter vivere insieme
agli altri e confrontarsi nella
possibilità di creare lavoro buono con
altri lontani da te insomma ho voluto
portare quel lavoro in italia in
sardegna in realtà gli abbiamo dato un
nome samp
tiscali il nome di una grotta dove
distanti
il nostro mito siano richiusi in
silenzio per proteggersi dalle invasioni
felice pensavamo di essere bravi
quell'impresa in atto dalla dalla
conoscenza dal fatto che da lui nel 1991
e sardegna si aperto un centro di
ricerche si chiamava crs4 sia venuto
carlo rubbia da cnet ra dove aveva visto
nascere il web qualche mese prima ci
abbia detto studiate su occupatevi di
web perché da lì
nasceranno delle cose interessanti 15
anni nel 1992
abbiamo iniziato altri hanno iniziato a
lavorarci nel 1993 è stato messo il
primo giornale on line in sardegna
insomma si è creata una cultura io nel
1994 fatto questa cosa praga nel 1998
sapevamo fare tante cose ed è nata una
società è nata con l'idea non di far
soldi con l'idea di creare la fabbrica
più bella della sardegna con l'idea di
dimostrare che il lavoro lo avremmo
creato noi che non ce l'avrebbe portato
nessuno da fuori perché l'avremo difeso
noi e che per fare il lavoro non
bisognava consumare il territorio tanto
meno distruggerlo non era necessario
inquinare non era necessario avere
contratti precari non era necessaria
trattar male la gente anzi si poteva
persino trattarla meglio per questo
facciamo
per questo faceva da questo facciamo il
primo asilo aziendale credo nel
mezzogiorno d'italia e per questo
avevamo e abbiamo il 99,5 per cento
delle persone occupate a tempo
indeterminato è stato un vento è stata
un'avventura bellissima la società dopo
un po è stata quotata abbiamo avuto le
risorse per crescere siamo cresciuti in
italia fuori dall'italia fuori in altri
paesi europei
nel 2003 fatturavamo circa un miliardo
di euro e più e avevamo diverse migliaia
di persone credo almeno 1.700 in
sardegna forse c'è voluto cogliere il
coraggio non vendere o non andare dietro
la chimera di trasformare quello che era
un valore diffuso in denaro voler
seguire un progetto industriale un sogno
di fare un industria che creasse lavoro
che lo creasse è che creasse bellezza
che creasse cultura che creasse
conoscenza che potesse diffondersi nel
paese che potesse cambiare un destino
che sembra scritto e che è scritto non è
a fine 2003 ho avuto una strana chiamata
nella vita di occuparmi della politica a
me non mi era mai capitato nemmeno dds
consigliere comunale non mi era mai
capitato nulla sapevo che quello che
facevamo aveva una sua responsabilità
sociale sapevo che quello che stavamo
facendo creare lavoro è un gesto
politico
sapevo che quello che stavamo facendo
era importante però ho avuto l'ambizione
di dire è più importante se lo facciamo
per un paese intero che per una società
è più importante se questa rivoluzione
dell'informatica e delle
telecomunicazioni questa rivoluzione
digitale questo ingresso in un mondo che
comunque stava cambiando lo possiamo
fare tutti insieme l'intera comunità e
non solo un'impresa ho avuto
un'esperienza politica che è durata
cinque anni mi sono ripresentato alle
elezioni e o perche stavo rientrando nel
lavoro in tiscali non ho ritrovato la
società dove la prima era una società in
un profondamente cambiata in crisi in
difficoltà si era ridotta in italia mi
sono accorto che non solo avevo appena
sbattuto sul muro con la politica
mentre vi stavo realizzando ho sbattuto
per la seconda volta in un altro muro
forse altrettanto duro era facile essere
coraggiosi da giovani erano passati
altri dieci anni di oggi ho 56 anni dai
fatti poi ho quattro figli grandi c'è
persino una poté che fa la crisi ma
domani c'è persino la responsabilità di
tante persone che lavorano con noi oggi
circa un migliaio
ho conosciuto la paura da grandi uno
cerca di mettere nel sicuro qualcosa
piuttosto che ripartiti piuttosto che
rialzarsi a rischiare di nuovo piuttosto
che rialzare e pensare che ancora una
volta poi scalare
montagna la paura mi ha aiutato molto e
forse mi ha insegnato più del coraggio
in atto e oggi sono un uomo migliore
forse grazie alla paura grazie al gli
scontri con i muri di granito e sono in
un percorso coraggioso con la paura in
tasca solo in un percorso di chi riparte
di chi ha rimesso in piedi la società
che kia sta assicurando il lavoro di
mille persone e riparte con gli attrezzi
del mestiere di ciascuno di noi che sono
l'intelligenza la forza d'animo la
passione per quello che facciamo
il sapere che i talenti che abbiamo ci
sono dati perché li usiamo e non perché
li nascondiamo sotto terra e sapere che
il sapere
che non siamo fatti per stare in un
porto siamo fatti per uscire nel mare
aperto è il mare aperto è fatto di vento
di bufere di onde alte ma alla fine si
arriva da qualche parte e non c'è un
luogo dove si arriva senza aver
affrontato le bufere senza aver
affrontato il pericolo non c'è un posto
dove si arriva gratis messaggio che
vorrei lasciarvi e di non aver paura di
gestirla la paura perché comunque non
c'è motivo di aver paura
da questa vita non riusciremo vivi tutto
quello che tutto quello che dovremmo
lasciare sicuramente non lasceremo e
quindi affrontiamo con coraggio perché
c'è un mondo meraviglioso avanti a noi
se sappiamo metterci in gioco in questo
momento così ti crisi di sfiducia di
difficoltà per ciascuno di noi per
ciascuna delle nostre imprese perciò per
il nostro paese
dobbiamo ricordarci che il mondo non è
in crisi il mondo anzi sta vincendo la
povertà più rapidamente di come non
abbia mai fatto nel passato nella storia
ci sono miliardi di persone che stanno
uscendo dalla fame dall'indigenza che
stanno diventando cittadini del mondo il
mondo sta corrente siamo noi che abbiamo
finalmente mettere da parte questa
rassegnazione questa paura allo scorso
per natale ci scambiamo gli auguri in
azienda
se mi è capitato di frasi augurio con
parole non mie con parole di einstein
sulla crisi
laddove dice non abbiamo non abbiate
paura della crisi la crisi un momento di
cambiamento ci costringe al cambiamento
all'innovazione a pensare strade nuove
che dobbiamo uscire dalla crisi non con
la stessa strada che in questa crisi ci
hanno portato mi ha fatto piacere vedere
vicino al duomo in una libreria appeso
un poster
le stesse frasi costano 4 euro consiglio
a tutti di contrario dentro di noi c'è
la forza per vincerla questa crisi c'è
la forza per cogliere l'importanza del
momento migliore della storia dell'uomo
non c'è mai stato un momento così
importante di pace di libertà per
tantissimi di noi un momento così
importante dove finalmente la cosa più
importante che vale di più non sono le
terre che ci ha lasciato nostro padre o
il bestiame o le ricchezze che qualcuno
ci ha lasciato e l'intelligenza e la
capacità di metterle a frutto la
capacità di istruirsi di innovare e di
creare con la fantasia come tanti ci
hanno testimoniato oggi questo non c'è
mai stato nel passato ognuno di noi è un
capitale come non lo è mai stato e
mentre l'accesso a scuola è più semplice
che nel passato a cerignola de vittorio
insegnava gratis
abbiamo persino accesso alla grande
università del mondo del pianeta con lo
streaming con le tecnologie che
conosciamo
insomma il futuro è nelle nostre mani e
allora coraggio a ciascuno di noi
coraggio al sud e coraggio all'italia